Rabbi Soloveitchik,
worthy Rabbis, friends.
First, my thanks to Al [inaudible] and
to Bernie Steinberg, who made this rather
glorious capping of a very active and
fruitful year of programming possible.
A wise man once said, "Let a teacher
beware, for he knows not how far his
influence extends." And there are
some teachers, the lucky few, who
occasionally touch a life here or touch
a life there, and those whose lives have
been touched may influence yet others.
But all of us here know, students
and teachers alike, that there
really aren't many of these who
have even that kind of privilege.
But tonight, we have as our speaker a
man who's recognized as the spiritual
and intellectual mentor of the majority
of Orthodox rabbis serving in this
country today, who has touched directly
and indirectly the lives of thousands,
kindled in many a heart what the
poet calls the inextinguishable fire.
And he does so not simply because of
his position at Yeshiva University,
Rabbi Isaac Elchanan Theological
Seminary, he does it not because of
any kind of official position, but
because of the quality of the man.
And Holmes put it beautifully once when
he said, "If a man is great, he makes
others believe in greatness; he makes
them incapable of mean ideals and easy
self-satisfaction." It's "The ferment
of genius in its creative moment," which
inspires others and gives rise again to
borrow from Holmes, "The enthusiasm of the
lecture-room, the contagious interest of
companionship," these things which "make
the students partners in their teacher's
work," in the finest sense of that word.
And who is this man, Rabbi
Joseph Ber Soloveitchik?
Scion of Brisk, that famous
family, who, in 1930, was awarded the
PhD in philosophy at the University of
Berlin, and a recognized authority in
secular philosophy, himself a master
of Talmudic scholarship, and one
who's able to blend the wisdom of the
one with the insights of the other.
This teacher, who cannot be measured
simply by the students in his classroom
in the conventional sense, or even by
those, the many, a surprising number, who
each year choose to brave a Massachusetts
summer to be with him in intensive study
for the full period, but not even this
suffices to give even a glimmering.
His famous lectures, the yahrzeit shiurs,
the pre-holiday lectures, when mature
scholars, rabbis, and pulpits from
miles and miles around, informed
baalei batim flock and crowd the halls
to listen and thereafter to discuss.
And throughout all this period, in
addition, he has served as Chief Rabbi of
Boston, creator of institutions, leader
of his flock and yet, when offered the
post of Chief Rabbi of Israel some years
ago, he made the choice that he preferred
to spend his time primarily in the halls
of learning, saying shiurim, touching
the lives of others, I would say, in
his role as teacher of a generation.
And today, I say no more, for in
a very literal sense, I think our
tradition demands that someone far
greater in stature than I could ever
aspire to be would be required even
to attempt assessment, but I think it
is permissible to mention the topic.
And his topic today, the very
formulation of it, he speaks a
variety of disciplines and of culture.
He speaks on prayer and
redemption and halachic equate.
We are privileged tonight to hear
the Rav, as he is affectionately
known, Rabbi Joseph Ber Soloveitchik.
Rabbi Soloveitchik.
Thank you very much, Doctor
Leo Levin, for your kind words.
[Inaudible]
Let me reintroduce myself.
I am not a philosopher, and
certainly not a theologian.
I am a teacher,
and I like teaching.
For me, teaching is not just a
profession but an experience.
My field is halachah.
I'm a teacher of Talmud,
and my field is halachah.
I've always believed
that the halachah embraces a double
order, an objective, abstract order.
The halachah is very abstract.
Basically, to study halachah
means to learn how to
construct [inaudible ]
So, there cannot be any
question of improvisation
[inaudible]
True, we are just concerned
with correspondence.
The experience corresponds
to a certain halachic act.
I'll try tonight, with your permission,
to explore the experiential order
within the halachah of prayer.
What I'm going to say
will not be philosophy.
As I said, I'm not a philosopher.
I would not engage in
the philosophical jargon.
Take my words right now as a
confession rather than a discourse.
I'll confide in you.
I'll tell you the story
of my prayer experience.
If you should say that my feelings
are sensible -- that's all what
I ask for -- I'll feel proud.
However, if you should dismiss them
as neurotic, I won't feel offended.
There's an old, old doctrine,
which is attributed to Plato, to
Kierkegaard, but actually Maimonides
said it in a more beautiful way:
the religious experience is madness.
Since I consider myself a
religious person, so I'm mad.
So if you'll dismiss them
as being neurotic,
I will not feel offended or insulted.
Now, with your permission, I'll start.
Redemption,
geulah, is a fundamental category in
Judaic thinking.
Our history, as a matter of fact,
was initiated by a
divine act of redemption.
We just celebrated the
holiday of Passover.
It's a holiday of redemption.
And our history will also be consummated
with a divine act of final, ultimate
redemption, the so-called
geulah atidah, the
messianic redemption.
The halachah, in a very strange,
almost enigmatic manner, has
identified redemption with prayer.
To pray means to redeem oneself.
To redeem oneself means to pray,
because an equation can be reversed.
And that equation of redemption
and prayer was, so to say,
subsumed under the famous halachah – I
mean, I don't know you, gentlemen,
but many among you probably know
the term semichas geulah l'tefillah.
It means geulah and
tefillah are identical.
And it is our custom that in the
morning, we say Go'al Yisrael, the
Redeemer of Israel, and then we start
the Shemoneh Esrei, which is the
tefillah, the prayer, immediately.
We don't even answer amen.
There is no Kaddish. It's a continuation.
The Birkat Geulah, I mean, the
benediction of geulah, is continued by
the first benediction in Shemoneh Esrei.
That's exactly what I'm going to explore.
What is redemption?
And I wish to remark, I'll
employ the so-called Spinoza or
Descartes method, more geometrico.
I'll try to somehow apply a
mathematical approach to what I'm
going to say, in the sense that
I'll postulate a few premises.
That means it's more of a
deductive approach
to the problem of prayer
and redemption.
Redemption portrays
a shift from the periphery to the
center of history, or, employing the
physical term, we may say redemption
can be described as the centripetal
movement from the
periphery toward the center.
Let me explain it.
Being on the periphery, actually,
means being a non-history-making
collective or group.
There are many groups which
are on the periphery, have
never moved toward the center.
Not only groups, even nations.
Being on the periphery means
to be a non-history-making collective.
While the movement toward the center
changes the same collective into a
history-making, history-involved,
and history-conscious, not a
collective anymore, but a people.
A history-making people leads -- it's
very hard on me to use the next
term -- a speaking, storytelling,
kerygmatic existence, an
existence with a message, kerygma.
While a non-history-making,
non-history-involved, and
non-history-conscious people
-- group, rather, I shouldn't say
people -- group is a non-communing,
a non-communicative, a silent entity.
History-making existence and a speaking
existence are identical concepts.
Now, the answer to the question which I
raised before, what is
redemption, is obvious.
Redemption is identical with
the revelation of the word.
When the word is revealed to a people,
the people is redeemed; or, it is
identical with the burgeoning of speech.
When a people leaves a mute world
and enters a world of sound,
a world of speech, a world of
song, the process of geulah,
of redemption, commences.
In other words, a mute life,
a silent life, is identical
with bondage, with slavery.
A speech-endowed life, a kerygmatic and
a communicative life, is a free life.
A slave lives in silence,
if he does live at all.
The free man has a lot to tell, and
is ready to tell the story of his
life to anyone who cares to listen.
Free Man has, indeed,
a message to put across.
The slave has no message,
has no story. He is silent.
The slave lacks the capacity not
only of speaking, as a matter of fact,
but of noise making,
or sound-emitting as well.
He's silent.
Not only wordless,
he's voiceless.
He is a mute being.
He is as quiet as the placid
lake on a quiet spring day.
What is responsible for the dumbness and
muteness of the slave, of the bonded man?
What is responsible for it?
After all, he is a human being.
I believe that responsible for it is the
lack of a basic experience, namely the
experience of suffering or the experience
of distress, which is perhaps the most
central aspect of the human "I" awareness.
You know, many
times, Descartes defined
man -- it's famous.
Descartes defined man.
Who is man?
What is man?
So, Descartes answered, man is a thinker.
Cogito ergo sum, an old
saying by Descartes.
I think, most probably, I do exist.
Of course, it's still
doubtful, but I do exist.
I would say Judaism's opinion of man
is -- and don't say it is a pessimistic
approach, it's not pessimistic at all.
I would say it in Latin, dolorem ferre
or pati, I suffer, ergo sum, I do exist.
The experience of suffering is
an integral part of the human "I"
consciousness, of the human awareness.
And I'll tell you my definition
is superior to Descartes'.
I mean, don't -- I'm not so great.
I'll tell you why.
Because Descartes' definition
applies to the devil, too.
Mephisto is an excellent thinker.
So, Mephisto can also say,
cogito ergo sum.
But my definition, dolorem ferre or
pati ergo sum, is not
applicable to the devil.
The devil doesn't suffer.
Only a genuine human being suffers.
The slave lacks that experience
of dolorem ferre or pati ergo sum.
At this juncture,
let me introduce
something very elementary.
It almost borders on the vulgar,
but I have to introduce it.
I can't help myself.
The distinction between two
phenomena to which man is exposed,
namely, pain and suffering.
In Hebrew, it would be machov or
ke'ev and sevel.
Pain is a natural sensation.
It's basically a physiological reaction
on the part of the organism to any
kind of abnormality, particularly
to any kind of tissue pathology.
It is, as Aristotle upheld,
he knew -- he was a physician
himself, a naturalist, a physician.
He said that pain is the mechanical signal
which man receives whenever his
physical existence is menaced
or threatened from within.
It is, so to say, an integral part
of the security system of the body.
And apparently, the body -- the
security system of the body is, by
far, superior to the security
system of the White House.
[Laughter]
This instinctual reaction
is, as it is self-evident, immediate
and non-reflective, and it is not
restricted to humans.
The beast in the fields, the brute
in the woods, is also exposed
to and acquainted with pain.
In contrast to pain, suffering is not a
sensation, not at all, but an experience.
Suffering, basically, is a spiritual
reality, not a physiological
reality, a physical sensation.
Not at all.
It's a spiritual reality with
which only humans are confronted.
The animal has pain,
yes, but does not suffer.
This spiritual reality is usually
encountered by man whenever he stands in
danger to lose the sense either of his
existential security, as it is in the case
of an incurable disease rachmana litzlan.
If one is incurably ill, it's
not only a question of pain.
Pain, you have painkillers now.
More or less, medicine
knows how to control pain.
With the problem of suffering,
medicine cannot control suffering.
Or when he stands to lose his
existential dignity, as it is in
the case of public humiliation.
If a person is publicly
humiliated, he suffers.
He lost something, something of his
human awareness, the aspect of dignity.
When he's incurably ill, he suffers.
Not only is he exposed to pain;
again, he's losing something.
What does he stand to lose?
The existential awareness.
Whenever a merciless, indifferent,
sometimes cruel, sense of reality clashes
with the human need of awareness,
man suffers and finds himself in distress.
The slave
is certainly exposed to pain, so is
the animal, as we have said before.
When the slave meets with pain, he reacts
like the brute does – with uttering a
sharp and shrill sound – he also reacts,
and he utters a sharp and shrill sound.
However, I would just call it a howl.
The howl of the beast, as well
as the shriek of the slave,
lasts just a split second.
And it dies suddenly in the darkness
and in the hush of the night.
In a split second, all is silent again.
There is no aftermath to pain sensation
-- to the pain sensation of the slave.
There is no follow-up.
There's no complaint.
There's no request.
There's no protest.
There's no question, why and what.
The agonizing howl is heard for an
infinitesimal period, and it is solely due
to the convulsive reflexes of the body.
That's all.
The slave does not know suffering since he
lacks the very "need" awareness which
generates suffering if it clashes
with an indifferent everyday reality.
He is never in distress because he has
no human needs – an emphasis upon human,
upon the adjective –
he has no human needs.
The needs of a slave are
like a shriek, not human.
The etiology of his needs is
exclusively biological, not human.
Former inmates of the concentration
camps -- and I spoke with many -- told
me that with the passage of time,
they got used to everything.
Nothing disturbed them,
nothing surprised them anymore.
They were totally, totally
anesthetized against suffering.
Even the sharpness of pain
was considerably reduced.
The slave is silent.
He does not cry in a human fashion.
He certainly does not speak up.
He emits, of course, he emits a
shriek, but not a human sound.
Certainly, you don't hear
him pronounce a word.
I'm interested -- I am by
nature, I'm not a philosopher,
but I have a pretty good mind.
I have a sense for homiletics.
And to me, a thought,
no matter how well defined,
is incomplete as long as
I don't have a Midrash or an Aggadah
to support it, to back it up.
Let me introduce a Zohar, a beautiful
Zohar, but it's more than homiletics.
The Zohar projects here a beautiful picture
of the slave, of the silent slave.
I'll read it.
I have the text in Aramaic,
but you'll permit me to
read it in English, right.
Moses possessed the voice.
However, his speech was in bondage.
You know the story, Moshe told the
Almighty that he has uncircumcised
lips, he's a stutterer, so the
Zohar interprets it symbolically.
Not that it was physically, his
lips were physically uncircumcised,
but spiritually, he could not speak
because his speech was in bondage.
It's a literal translation of
the milei d'la havei b'galuta.
He was in bondage, and he
could not pronounce the words.
His lips were uncircumcised.
That's why he refused to go to Pharaoh.
The lips were enslaved.
“I cannot”, Moses said, “utter sounds”.
“I can”, Moses said, “utter
sounds, but not words”.
Before Moses came -- and the
Zohar continues to tell us
a very strange story.
Before Moses came, not only
speech but even sound was not present.
With Moses' appearance, the
voice was found or was restored,
yet it was a wordless sound.
The word was still in exile.
Only when the people, with Moses,
came to the Mount Sinai and the law
was given, the word was rediscovered
and was united with the voice,
and the word was spoken.
Interesting it is, that the Zohar
here speaks of three phases within
the process of geulah, of redemption.
First phase,
the stage of total silence.
This means total slavery, total bondage.
Second, that of sound but not of speech.
Third, that of total speech,
clear, unequivocal speech.
The first one, total silence,
characterizes slavery.
The last one, clear
speech, full redemption.
The middle one, when the person begins to move from the silent mute periphery
toward the center of speech, the process
of geulah sets in and the man is on
his way to complete redemption.
Before Moses came, there
was not even a voice.
No sound was heard.
No complaint was lodged against them.
No sigh, no cry was
uttered, just an agonizing, inhuman shriek
used to penetrate the hush or the weird
silence of an otherwise quiet night.
The slaves were silent.
They were gloomy but voiceless.
The women did not cry, did not protest,
did not fight, did not put up resistance
when their infants were snatched away
from their arms and drowned in the Nile.
The men kept quiet when they were
mercilessly tortured by
the slave drivers.
Yes, they felt pain, but
they did not suffer at all.
They took torture for granted.
They thought this is the way it should be.
They had no needs.
They lacked one awareness, the
"need" awareness, the awareness
of dolorem ferre ergo sum.
Moses, by his defending the helpless
Jew who was beaten by the Egyptian
slave driver, restored sensitivity to
the dull slaves, to the poor Hebrews.
They suddenly realized, in effect,
in a split second, they realized that
all that pain which they took for granted,
hundreds of years -- we don't know
exactly how many years
they spent in Egypt, but
they took pain for
granted hundreds of years.
All that pain, all that anguish, all
that humiliation and endless torture are
unwarranted.
They realized suddenly,
unjustified, uncalled
for, that all the cruelty, greed,
intolerance of man vis-à-vis his
fellow man is evil, human madness.
They suddenly became perplexed, confused.
They were not confused before,
because they understood everything.
That's what they thought.
They took it for granted.
They didn't protest against reality.
Reality cannot be changed.
But suddenly, they
became perplexed, confused.
And in this confusion and
perplexity, usually suffering
comes, anguish comes.
Suddenly,
they began to protest.
I mean, the story of the Russian
Jewry is exactly, beautifully
portrayed by that Zohar.
You will find the same phases in
the process of redemption of
Russian Jews as the Zohar describes
concerning our ancestors in Egypt.
Suddenly, the
question arose, a wordless question
yet, the wordless demand for justice
and retribution, for change, et cetera.
In short, their silence was gone.
Moses brought to the Jews the voice.
And the voice means the
awakening of an emotional
awareness of need, or the consciousness
of delorem ferre, of pati, and I want to
understand why I am supposed to suffer.
Suddenly, the existence of the
poor Hebrews in Egypt became not a
speaking one but a vocal existence.
They engaged in noise-making, in
emitting sounds, into a vocal existence.
The voice was restored to them.
And interesting is how the Bible tells us:
"Vayehi ba'yamim ha'rabim ha'hem va'yamas
melech Mitzrayim vayei'anchu Bnei
Yisrael min ha'avodah va'yizaku va'taal
shavasom el ha'Elokim min ha'avodah."
And it came to pass in the course of
the many days that the king of Egypt
died, and the Children of Israel sighed
by reason of the bondage, and they
cried, and their cry came up unto God.
So, there's a very simple question.
This happened after Moses'
appearance in Egypt.
What happened before he appeared in Egypt?
Why didn't they cry before
the Moses episode took place?
Why were they silent during the
hundreds of years that they spent in
slave camps prior to Moses' appearance?
Apparently, their pre-Mosaic
existence was a mute and silent one.
They lacked the basic "need" awareness.
They experienced no need.
If you have no need, you
don't know the secret that
freedom is indispensable and that
freedom is the greatest of human needs.
Hence, they were in no
conflict with reality.
And that conflict with reality
between the human need and reality
generates suffering and distress.
The voice is restored to man
at the very instant his emotional "need"
awareness awakens, the very instant
he becomes sensitive to human pain.
Not just pain, I'm saying human pain.
However, speech comes later,
appears much later, with the birth
not of the awareness of need but
with the birth of the logos of need.
There is not only awareness of need.
I feel, I have a desire, I have an urge.
I am driven to obtain something.
Not only that,
this is, I would say, an
emotional awareness of need.
It's very important.
It's the basis.
But apart from the emotional awareness
of need, there is a logos of need.
I understand why -- I want to understand why I need it.
What is the purpose?
And how can I get it?
When I become aware of my needs,
so I am already -- I get my voice, my voice is restored.
But the word is given to me and I become not only aware of my need,
but I begin to understand my need.
Not only understand my need,
I understand also the method in which I could gratify that need.
Speech, however, appears much later with the birth of the logos of the need,
or with the emergence of a cognitive,
value-oriented, or let us use the term, axiological, "need" awareness.
There is an emotional "need" awareness , which is not as yet value-oriented.
There is a "need" awareness
if one is addicted to drugs.
It's also a "need" awareness.
If I'm addicted to alcohol,
it's a "need" awareness.
It's a very strong awareness.
It's powerful.
You know that.
It may destroy a man.
But what is the addict lacking?
What is he lacking?
Not the "need" awareness.
He's lacking the logos of need,
or the relationship of an
emotional "need" awareness to a
value-oriented, cognitive awareness.
This is the logos of need.
And interesting is, that the Zohar
says Moses was the voice,
but he had no words.
Even the great Moses, who was moving from
the silent periphery to the great center,
did not arrive at his destination before
he and his people reached Mount Sinai.
For while he
was need-conscious, he was the
first one to emit a human sound of
protest, of non-reconciliation of the
human being with reality, no
matter how powerful reality is
The first -- he actually emitted
the first meaningful cry.
He did not, as yet,
discover the logos of need,
which should
have bestowed upon him the word.
Yes, he felt that the situation was
abnormal and that change was inevitable.
However, he did not know what to do
in order to liberate the people from
the clutches of a monstrous reality.
He experienced, intuitively, shame
and disgrace of such a mute existence.
His "need" awareness was extremely
sensitive, yet he failed to formulate
his feelings in clear, unequivocal words.
He lacked the
logos of need, even though
he had the awareness of need.
The word was missing.
Moses protested, he killed the tyrant,
he rebuked the wicked Jew, et cetera.
Nevertheless, he did not believe that
those slaves would ever be liberated.
He didn't believe in it.
You know, God had an argument with him.
According to Midrashic interpretation,
a full week God spent arguing with
Moses to convince him that those
slaves, insensitive slaves, who took
everything for granted, are worthy
of liberation, and those slaves will
turn into a great mamlechet kohanim,
into a kingdom of priests.
The whole situation was bewildering.
Yes, Moses broke the silence.
He began to move toward the
living, speaking center; however,
the word was still missing.
The logos of need was
not revealed to Moses.
And that revelation took place
when Moses reached Mount Sinai.
Then, he understood the meaning
of liberation, and he also
understood his people, that his
people are a very funny group.
They can rise from a
silent existence to an existence
full of sound and song and
speech within seven weeks.
They can fall into a bottomless
abyss quickly, but they can
rise to the stars suddenly.
That Moses understood
at Mount Sinai.
And then, the word was bestowed upon
him, the greatest gift
that God bestows upon man.
Now, let me continue if you
are not tired to listen.
Slavery
is not only a political,
juridic institution.
It's not only a political,
juridic reality.
It's more than that.
It is even more than a
psychological reality.
Slavery, or bondage, is
an existential reality.
I would say, a modus essendi.
It's a way of life.
You'll ask me -- and certainly, you would
ask me if you wanted to interrupt
me -- how does existential
slavery express itself?
We know how juridic, political
slavery expresses itself.
We know that.
But how does existential slavery
demonstrate itself, manifest itself?
How?
What is it?
What kind of an existence is it?
I'll answer you immediately.
In a peripheral existence.
If a person leads a peripheral
existence,
he is a slave existentially.
I'll tell you – I mean, luckily, I'm a
rabbi, as Dr. Levin told you, I'm a rav.
Unfortunately – not unfortunately,
gratefully – there was a secular
Jewish writer who described the
existential slave in a beautiful manner.
I could have picked other quotations
from other writers, but I believe
he did it in a magnificent fashion.
This is Peretz.
We all know the story of
Bontshe Shvayg.
Many of you know.
I don't know how many know.
If I were in my class, I would
tell you raise your hand, right?
Not those who know, those who don't know.
But there is
just at the beginning.
The whole story I don't like.
It's too sarcastic.
It's even cynical.
However, the description of Bontshe
Shvayg -- the name itself, shvayg,
means silence -- is beautiful.
Shall I read the beginning in Yiddish or
you want me to give you the translation?
In Yiddish.
Yiddish in the beginning,
all right, I understand.
Peretz starts with the following
paragraph: "Da oyf der velt hot Bontshe
Shvayg's toyt gor keyn ayndruk gemakht.
Fregt imatsen becherem ver Bontshe Shvayg iz geven.
Bontshe hot shtil gelebt un iz shtil geshtorbn;
vi a shotn iz er durkh gegangen undzer velt.
Oyf Bontshe's bris hot men keyn vayn
nisht getrunken, es hobn keyn koyses
geklungen, tsu bar mitzveh hot er
keyn klingendike droshe nisht gezogt.
Gelebt hot er vi a groy kleyn
kerndl zamd baym breg fun
yam, tsvishn milyonen zayns glaykhn.
Az der vint hot'n oyfgehoybn un
oyf der anderer zayt yam
aribergeyogt hot es
keyner nisht bamertkt."
Now, it's my translation, I wanted to say.
Find fault, find it with me, not
with Peretz: Bontshe Shvayg's death
made no impression whatsoever.
No one knew who Bontshe was.
Bontshe lived mutely and died quietly.
Like a silent shadow, he
did pass through our world.
At Bontshe's circumcision, no toasts
were raised, no glasses were clinked.
At bar mitzvah, no rousing
speech was delivered.
He lived in anonymity like a
gray, minute grain of sand on the
beach of a stormy sea, among
millions of identical sand particles.
No one noticed
that one of the particles was picked up by
the storm wind and carried far, far away.
[Inaudible]
They are slaves, not in a juridic fashion
but in an existential sense.
They are faceless; they are nameless.
No one is interested in them.
No one is concerned with or about them.
No one rejoices in their presence,
and no one bemoans their absence.
They come and go like Peretz's
Bontshe Shvayg without leaving
a trace, without making a mark.
They are forgotten people.
The cemeteries are full of them.
The death notice and the obituary page
in a paper, if such a notice did appear,
or the inscription on the tombstone,
is the only reminder that somebody
existed somewhere, sometime ago.
Those people lack, like the slave
of antiquity, a "need" awareness.
They know not what suffering is.
They are, therefore, speechless.
They are even voiceless.
Man was endowed with voice
and speech in order to react.
God gave him speech and voice in
order to react in a human fashion
to suffering, in order to be able
to define and articulate his needs.
With the disappearance of
a "need" awareness, one
forfeits voice and speech as well.
But let me add something.
We have been speaking about some
people, like Bontshe Shvayg, who
lead a peripheral, silent existence.
This is not true.
May I use this term, Judaic
existentialism, because the oldest
book on existentialism is not Pascal
or Augustine but the Tehillim.
This is the oldest book on existentialism.
To attribute existentialism to
Augustine or to Pascal or to
Kierkegaard is simply plagiarism.
They all plagiarized the Tehillim.
Judaic existentialism has
gone a step further.
It has frankly stated that not some of
the people lead a silent or peripheral
existence, they are bondsmen, slaves.
This is true, but it's not the full truth.
Judaism has frankly stated that
all the people are existentially
peripheral, mute beings, fringe dwellers.
no matter how vocal and
no matter how energetic they are.
When the Ecclesiastes said, "Ki
ba'choshech ba u'va'choshech
yelech u'va'choshech shemo
yechuseh," for it comes
in vanity, and departs in darkness, and
the name thereof is covered with darkness.
He did not refer only to the timid soul,
to the poor and meek, the Bontshe Shvaygs,
but to everybody, to the great ruler,
to the daring warrior, to the captain
of industry, and to the famous orator.
No matter how prestigious an
existence he lives in his terms,
he lives on the outskirts of being.
We have developed before the
equation of silence and the
absence of a "need" awareness.
Judaism holds the view that no
individual has a right to boast that
he possesses the right sensitivity
to and knowledge of his needs.
Not even the most sophisticated
and the most enlightened person is
familiar with his genuine needs.
In fact, man is totally
ignorant, even of his most
cardinal needs, urges, and desires.
And here comes in a very strange
philosophical doctrine which plays
an important role in Judaism.
The double image doctrine, which plays
such a significant role in our philosophy
of sin and repentance, lies at the very
root of our pessimistic appraisal of
man's relationship to his own needs.
Sin in Judaism -- what I mean by the
double image theory is as follows.
Sin in Judaism, in contradistinction to
Christian theology since Augustine, is
not within man but extraneous to man.
It's something foreign to man.
The cause of sin is to be found
not in man, not in genuine man, but
in the identification of man with
the wrong image,
with a phony “I” awareness.
If man identifies himself with
a pseudo, with the pseudo “I”,
with a phony “I” awareness, then
that identification breeds sin.
What is repentance according to Judaism?
Maimonides formulated it in one sentence.
Repentance is the consequence
of rediscovery of the genuine
“I”, of the genuine image,
and sin means the wrong identification.
Now, let us draw a very simple
conclusion. If Man has a tendency to
identify himself with the wrong “I”
personality, then he'll also want to
respond to the needs of that personality.
We are very ambitious.
As a matter of fact, modern
man has countless needs,
but they don't belong to him.
They are needs of somebody else.
In a word, not only some people live
on the periphery, but all of us.
Man, with the wrong table of
needs is not a full being.
And at this point, another Judaic
doctrine comes to the fore,
namely the activist doctrine.
Activist is probably a very fashionable
word among the Russian Jews who
call them -- those who stand up
and speak are called activists.
But it is a Judaic activist
doctrine of self-redemption.
What does this doctrine say?
Maimonides, in my opinion – I don't know
whether some historians will agree with me
or not – in my opinion, this is a central
doctrine in Maimonides' Moreh Nevuchim.
It comes to expression, unfortunately,
not in this first part, and not in
the middle part, but in the last part.
Usually, historians forget
about the last part.
The story is about the Alshich, an
old Jew said that he became a heretic,
an apikores, because of the Alshich.
Because the Alshich has the habit of
formulating maybe 20, 25 questions, and
then he begins to resolve the questions.
It was Shabbos, and the Jew
was tired after the meal.
So, the questions he did read,
but the answers, by the time he
was supposed to read the answers,
he was asleep, sound asleep.
So, he was -- after a certain
period of time, he found himself
full of questions without answers.
This is the trouble with
Maimonides, that actually this
theory was expounded by Maimonides
in the third section of Moreh Nevuchim.
What does this theory say?
I believe this doctrine says as follows.
Man comes into our world as a hyletic – I
mean, I'm using the Aristotelian jargon,
but I don't have a better word for that.
It means what we call in our
traditional medieval philosophical
jargon, chomer hiyuli.
I mean, some people heard it.
Chomer hiyuli means there is
potency, but there is no actuality.
It's called hyle in Greek.
He comes as a hyletic,
amorphous being.
He is created, of course,
in the image of God.
However, this image is a
challenge, is an idea, or
I would rather say it's an ideal.
It's a twinkling star on a far horizon.
It is not a grant, a gratuitous grant, but
God gives man the divine
image just for the asking.
It is up to man to take an ideal and
translate it into a reality; to reach
out for the twinkling star, no matter
how distant man is from that star.
It's up to man to objectify himself,
to impress form upon a latent, formless,
even though a divine personality, and to
move from the hyletic, silent periphery to
the center of objective, formed reality.
This is basically the idea,
according to Maimonides.
I don't have to tell you that,
the ideal of education.
The highest norm in Maimonidean
moral code is rather strange.
What would you say?
I mean, knowing Maimonides,
what does he consider
the highest moral norm?
A very short norm.
To be.
To exist.
Maimonides did
not have Hamlet's doubts
whether to be or not to be.
If it is to be, it means play, to exist.
But to exist, in Maimonides, means
to draw out of myself the genuine
“I”, which is sometimes hidden
in the distant recesses of my personality.
To be in a corporal sense,
to liberate oneself from the bondage
of a shadowy – and I'll use now
here also a Platonic term because
it says something which I cannot
translate – Plato spoke of “me on”.
“On” means being, reality.
“Me on” means non-reality,
half-reality, semi-reality.
Somehow, it's a chaotic state, I believe.
Man does exist, but not fully.
From the shadows of “me on” and make
man move toward the white spaces that
Plato calls “ontos on”, real being,
genuine being, full being, total being.
In the world of ontos on,
there is speech, there is sound,
there is color, there is song.
The world of me on is full of shadows.
And what is education for
Maimonides is to take man out
of this, basically, emigration.
The Russians don't like it, but actually,
to take man out of the realm of shadows
and place him in the realm of light;
take him out of the realm of silence,
muteness, and place him in the
realm of speech and the clear word.
How is it being done?
How do we achieve this
objectification of the human being?
How?
All right, it's a beautiful idea: to be!
To be in a total sense.
But how?
Judaism recommended
two acts of redemption.
Try to guess.
One, through knowledge.
It means in our vocabulary,
it means through Torah.
The redemption of the intellect
or objectification redemption of
the intellect through knowledge,
through cognition, through Torah.
Second, through tefillah.
The redemption -- of course,
the Torah redeems the intellect.
What does tefillah redeem?
The "need" awareness or the
awareness of dolorem
ferre, or pati, ergo sum.
It's important in Judaism.
It's the basic awareness in a human being.
With your permission, I'll
just explain in a few sentences
how does the intellectual
object – the process of objectification,
the process of intellectual
objectification – how does it function?
And it will facilitate my
task of explaining to you
how the objectification via
tefillah occurs.
We all know the story
that is related in Nidah Daf Lamed 30b.
I mean, if someone wants to check
I have it.
I cut it out.
I have it right here, but
I'll give my own translations.
It's much better than
the standard translation.
But if somebody should doubt my word and
say, I mean, it's my own story, I made
it up, so I have it right over here.
We all know the story told in Tractate
Nidah about the angel who teaches
Torah, the whole Torah from beginning
to end, to the embryo or fetus during
the nine months of its incubation -- the
greatest scholar is the embryo -- and
who strikes the baby upon its face,
upon its mouth, immediately before
the baby is ready to see light
and is to be born, before birth.
And that same angel
who taught the baby
the whole system of law, the
whole Torah from beginning to
end, makes it forget everything.
Of course, when a baby comes
into this world, we know very
well it doesn't know too much.
As a matter of fact, this story actually
was translated into a certain custom.
The reason why people visit the baby or
the mother on the Shabbat before the bris
is the tragedy which happened to the baby.
It's basically a condolence visit we pay
to the baby, that the baby's in mourning.
It was such a great scholar, and there
was no need to pay tuition and to look
for admission to some Ivy League college,
and suddenly, it has forgotten everything.
Jews are very sympathetic, merciful.
They pay a condolence visit.
Ha'makom yinachem, God should comfort.
That's what our task is.
The question is obvious.
If the angel makes the baby forget
everything he taught it, so then why did
he bother to teach the embryo at all?
It's a waste of time.
The answer, I believe, is
again obvious and clear.
When a Jew
studies Torah, he is confronted with
something which is not foreign to him, not
superimposed upon him from the outside.
He is confronted with something which is
not extraneous to him, but with something
which is intimate and known from before.
He knew all that once upon a time.
It was stored up in the
recesses of his memory.
Of course, he
studies his own stuff
by sheer association.
You know very well, by sheer association,
we are reminded of the Platonic doctrine
that learning is recalling, recollection.
It's the same doctrine.
What does it mean?
Learning means recollecting
of something familiar.
The Jew studying Torah acts like
the amnesia victim who is trying
hard to reconstruct out of the
debris of his memory a beautiful
world which, intuitively, he knows.
He can prove it.
He enjoyed it once upon a time.
In other words, by learning Torah,
the Jew expands his own self.
To study means to objectify
and to redeem oneself from the
hyletic, from the silent existence.
By studying, a Jew heads straight toward
a charted, illuminated and speaking
existence, but everything is within him.
He draws it out of himself.
Education as drawing out of oneself.
That's exactly what Rabbi
Simlai -- the name of
the rabbi who taught this story is
Rabbi Simlai -- wanted to convey to us.
Now, just
in short, I want to say intellectual
redemption of study, which is achieved
through study of Torah, has also the three
phases which the Zohar mentioned vis-à-vis
our ancestors in Egypt.
First of all, at the first stage, we
encounter silence, complete intellectual
insensitivity and total unconcern.
You may meet people,
they are not educated somehow.
It's not a question.
They didn't have the opportunity.
But they are totally unconcerned.
They don't possess this curiosity or,
what Aristotle called, the amazement,
the “why?” or “what?”, that man
willy-nilly utters when he is confronted
by the cosmos, by the universe.
They lack it.
Silence.
There is no awareness of need.
You start with every baby like that.
Unfortunately, some people
grow up with this awareness.
That world, during that period
of time, when man is unconcerned,
completely unconcerned, he's
not amazed and takes
everything for granted.
He simply doesn't react to
the beauty of the universe.
After all, God has showered so
much beauty upon this universe.
Nor does he react to the
intellectual aspect, to the
scientific question, why, what, how.
This is hyle.
Complete potentiality, but no actuality.
It is the world of shadows.
It is the world of silence.
Then comes the second phase.
As a teacher, I know that the
second phase is not the word.
Word is the idea, the voice.
It means the pupil – somehow the
pupil's voice was restored, or
the voice is restored to man.
It means you hear sounds but not words.
The awakening: it
characterizes the awakening of
cognitive curiosity and amazement.
Man begins to be annoyed
because he does not understand.
He is troubled by something he
himself cannot define, and that
is the beginning of knowledge.
This is the voice.
This is a transitional stage.
Of course, at the end, at the
conclusion comes the word.
The word breaks through.
What is the word in the intellectual
world, in the academic world?
Clear and distinct cognition.
The intellect begins to speak.
In that moment, the intellect begins
to speak, to ask and to answer.
It's more important that the
intellect asks the question.
There's not always an answer.
There are no answers to all
questions, but begins to speak in
the clear accents of the logos.
Then, man finds himself
objectified, redeemed and a citizen,
not of me on but of ontos on.
Now, let us ask, how does man
redeem himself through prayer?
This is actually my topic.
Judaism, in contradistinction to
mystical quietism
– and it's usually non-Jewish mysticism, the
Jewish mystics had a different approach
– but non-Jewish mysticism, throughout the
ages, recommended toleration of pain.
Judaism, in contradistinction to that
doctrine, wants man, as I said
already before, to cry out aloud
against any kind of pain, to react.
Judaism rejected Stoicism.
Some people are Stoics.
Maimonides himself was a Stoic.
He couldn't help it.
It was a part of him.
But Judaism as a whole, the halachah is
opposed to Stoicism, to taking pain
quietly, graciously, with magnanimity.
It wants man to react indignantly to
all kinds of injustice or unfairness.
For Judaism holds the view that the
individual who displays immunity
to pain and suffering, who meekly
reconciles himself to the ugly,
disproportionate and unjust in life, who
does not shudder at the sight of
the Satan, the individual who has
no needs at all, whose needs are
a few and easily gratified, that
individual will never be able to
appreciate beauty and goodness
and, particularly, to share in the
travail and the suffering of others.
Whoever permits his legitimate needs
to go unsatisfied will never be
sympathetic to the crying needs of others.
Human morality, which is based on
love and friendship, on sharing
in the travail of others, cannot
be practiced if the person's own
“needs” awareness is dull and meek.
If the individual himself knows not
what suffering is, then he'll never
share in the suffering of others.
Hence, Judaism rejected what
kind of an existence?
Probably aesthetic.
Aesthetic, yeah, but I have a better term.
The angelic existence.
You all know the Aggadah.
The angels appeared before the Almighty
and said they wanted the Torah.
Why would the Torah be given to sinful
man, frail man, weak man, mortal man?
And why not be given to the
angels, to the archangels, who
live forever?
And what did God answer?
I give the Torah to a people with needs.
Angels live in an existence without need,
and the Torah does not belong to them.
Therefore, prayer in Judaism
is again, unlike prayer in the
mystical literature, bound up with
human needs,
human drives, human
urges, and human wants.
Out of the 19 benedictions in our Shemoneh
Esrei, in our Tefillat Amidah, 13 are
concerned exclusively with human
need, from Atah Chonen L'Adam
Daat until Shomei'a Tefillah.
And even two of the last three
benedictions, Retzeh and Sim Shalom,
are again concerned with need and they
display petitional, so to say, nature.
They are petitional benedictions.
Judaism was not too excited over
hymnal prayer or a thanksgiving prayer.
We know we have them.
We recite the Hallel on certain
occasions, and we recite Pesukei d'Zimra
every morning prior to the recital
of the benedictions of Kriat Shema.
Correct.
We have, you know, I mean– the Book
of Psalms is replete with hymns,
beautiful, magnificent hymns,
exalted hymns, but the hymn is
not the very essence of the Jewish prayer.
And the Jewish prayer,
the very essence, the very
substance of the Jewish prayer,
is petition, intercession,
asking, requesting, and sometimes
demanding from the Almighty.
It's very strange.
Christians don't understand it.
They have even trouble with
the Pater Noster, in the Lord's
Prayer, to give us our daily bread.
They have trouble.
We ask more than bread.
We ask for luxuries sometimes.
And that's exactly what
Judaism wants us to do.
The person in need is summoned to pray.
And halachically, I could prove it
to you, but I have no time for that.
Prayer and tzarah.
you know what tzarah is, I mean?
Either you say it in Sephardic
dialect or in Ashkenazic
dialect, it's the same tzarah.
Prayer is inseparably linked
up, bound up with tzarah.
Who prays?
He who is in distress.
"Min ha'meitzar karasi Kah," out
of the narrow straits I invoke God.
"Mi'maamakim kerasicha Adoshem,"
I invoke God de profundis,
from the depths in which I find myself.
"V'chi savo milchamah b'artzechem al ha'tzaar ha'tzorer es'chem,"
when we're at war with them,
then pray.
And this is true according to
Maimonides as well, and Nachmanides,
who dealt with the problem of
prayer from a halachic viewpoint.
Prayer and need are inseparably bound up.
If man does not experience min ha'meitzar,
narrowness, existential narrowness, if
man is not in distress, min ha'meitzar,
if he's not somewhere in subterranean
depths, if he feels happy and contented,
there is halachically no need for prayer.
Doesn't have to join a temple or
synagogue, and can save a few dollars.
If man is happy,
contented, prayer not only is not
necessary but it's an absurdity.
Prayer is the result of this
consciousness, of a permanent crisis
consciousness, the consciousness
of dolorem ferre ergo sum.
This is prayer.
Of course, with
the awakening of the "need"
awareness , prayer is dependent
upon the "need" awareness.
If a man has a "need" awareness, then pray, ask, demand, request.
If you have
no "need" awareness, either your
needs are few, or you think you
have gratified all your needs,
then there is no need for prayer.
With the awakening of the "need"
awareness, prayer makes its entry.
Prayer at this stage -- and I would ask
for your attention -- at this stage,
is called tzaakah, Tzaddi-Ayin-Kuf-Hei,
tzaakah, not tefillah yet.
Not tefillah yet.
Tefillah is a higher word.
I'll explain what tefillah is.
Tzaakah, Tzaddi-Ayin-Kuf-Hei,
what does tzaakah mean in Hebrew?
Shriek, outcry.
And one of the attributes of the
Almighty is Shomei'a Kol Tzaakah.
He hearkens to the voice, to the cry,
to the shriek, to the howl.
He hearkens to it.
Not word, kol tzaakah.
You don't say Shomei'a Kol Tefillah.
You don't say it because when God hearkens
to tefillah, then He hearkens to words.
But when it is about tzaakah,
there are no words yet.
Man hasn't discovered the logos of need.
He just discovered the awareness
of need, that he is a being
in need.
He is dependent, and the consummation of
the ideal of man, of his life – I mean,
the meaningfulness – can only be obtained
from somewhere else, not from within.
Then, prayer is indispensable.
But this is the logos.
For the time being, it is
just tzaakah, just an outcry.
There is as yet no word, no
sentence, even though the
emotional awareness has awakened.
The logos of need is
still dormant, silent.
There is, as yet, no clear
understanding of what one is crying for.
There is, however, distress
and loud human weeping.
Tzaakah is primordial prayer.
The voice is restored;
the word is still missing.
He prays because he's in narrow straits.
He prays because
he is in the depths.
But for what he prays, he doesn't know.
Did our ancestors in Egypt know
when they began to pray for what?
Prayer was an expression of protest
against reality, against the present.
But what?
How it should be changed?
What man wants?
At this stage, he doesn't know as yet.
Interesting is, I mean, just as this
is a parenthetical statement, that
the service of Selichot, I mean, the
original service of Selichot, actually
represents not tefillah but tzaakah.
Short sentences.
"Ana Adoshem hoshi'ah na."
Aneinu, aneinu, aneinu, you
just repeat one word.
Aneinu, answer, hearken,
aneinu, aneinu, aneinu.
Later, it was elaborated and,
of course, transformed into
literary creations, but at the
beginning, it was just an outcry, a
shriek, a word whose meaning, I mean,
the worshipper did not understand.
Aneinu, mi sh'anah l'Avraham Avinu
b'Har Hamoriah, aneinu, ateret libi.
The shaliach tzibbur, the cantor, used to
say the sentence, the crowd couldn't read.
They didn't know how to
formulate the prayer.
They just answered in monosyllables
or just with one word.
Aneinu, hoshana, hoshana, hoshana.
This is the stage of tzaakah.
A "need" awareness has
awakened.
Man feels reality has to
be corrected, changed.
Man registers protest
against reality, but
he doesn't know what the substitute is.
This is tzaakah.
Let us continue.
Now, we come to tefillah.
Let us continue with our analysis.
There is an inner contradiction
within the "need" awareness.
I know my own opinion, I mean,
I've spoken so much about it
and I mentioned it in my essay.
The awareness of need is a
dialectical awareness, basically.
It means it has
an inner contradiction.
On the one hand, it urges man, as I stated
before, to gratify his needs and warns
him against any attempt to suppress them,
since non-gratification is
contrary to human dignity.
You see?
The first aspect of the awareness
of need is not only just that I
am in need: a statement of fact.
But there is a normative
element, a normative aspect.
Gratify.
Try to gratify your needs.
Don't suppress them because suppression
of needs and the denial of gratification
to needs is contrary to the
divine scheme of creation
and to dignity of man.
However, there is another
aspect in the awareness of need.
It also warns man against
total gratification
of his needs.
Some needs,
and to our chagrin, the most pressing
ones, must and will never be gratified.
That's what Judaism says.
The awareness of need is
of a dialectical nature.
It has an inner contradiction.
There are two aspects which
are mutually exclusive.
One aspect is: gratify your needs.
Gratification is incumbent upon man.
It is incumbent upon man
to gratify his needs.
If man tries to suppress his
needs like monastic philosophy or
asceticism would recommend, then
he's actually lowering his dignity.
On the other hand, there's another aspect.
Total gratification.
To become an addict?
To become a voluptuary?
To gratify every need
and totally gratify?
Forbidden.
It's forbidden.
You shouldn't do that.
Some needs
deserve to be gratified, some needs
should be suppressed or, rather,
excluded from the human "need" awareness.
Suppression is the word
which Judaism does not like.
The "need" awareness tells man
that total gratification will in the
long run, could in the long run, destroy
man's dignity and man's humanity.
What should man do in such a case?
What should he do?
He's caught in the
crucible of contradiction.
What advice should he follow?
Advice number one, gratification of
needs is a human performance and man
will enhance his dignity by gratifying
his needs, or should he listen and pay
attention to the advice to
just the reverse?
Namely, total gratification
of needs is forbidden.
You will lose your human dignity
if you'll succumb to need.
Of course, Judaism comes forward
with a complete axiological
doctrine of human needs.
It tries to teach man which needs should
and which should not be gratified.
This is basically the essence of halachah.
You'll ask
me what halachah is recommending man,
the modus operandi, how man should relate
himself to both aspects of the "need"
awareness, to the aspect which recommends
gratification and to the aspect which
tells him total gratification is insane
and means destruction of the personality.
There are criteria by which one may be
guided in his attempt to treat his needs,
his "need" awareness on a selective basis.
The halachic prayer, it's hard for me
now – time is almost up.
You don't know how much time
I allocated to myself, huh?
I didn't ask you.
So, I could prove it to you by
studying each brachah separately.
For the brachos, for those
benedictions contain not only the
fact that man has needs but also
a scale, a hierarchy of needs.
Instructs man to distinguish
between worthwhile, constructive
gratification of need
and a disjunctive one.
It means that in addition to
the awareness of need, man
must what?
Must also possess the logos, I
mentioned before, the logos of need.
Man should not only be sensitive
to his needs but also know
and evaluate them as well.
He's supposed to relate them
to moral norms and their
gratification, thus ethicized.
There are no neutral
activities in Judaism.
There is no division of sectors
into mundane and sacred.
Every sector in human life can either
serve as a sanctuary for God or
deteriorate into a madhouse of profanity
and absurdity, and it's up to man
to decide.
And the main decision, the most
important decision that man makes, is
concerned with the problem of
need, which needs be gratified
and which eliminated
and disowned by man.
At this stage – and this is in
the Shemoneh Esrei – there is
a hierarchy of needs, beginning
with Atah Chonen and closing,
concluding with Shomei'a Tefillah.
At this stage, prayer is not
just a shriek, not just a cry,
and not just a howl anymore.
It is rather a well-defined
thought, a clear conception.
Therefore, at this stage, when
man introduces the logos of
needs, it turns into tefillah.
What the exact semantics of tefillah, of
the term tefillah is, we do not know.
It's very hard.
There are many opinions,
but one thing we do know.